all right i have for you today some of
the funniest
video i've seen come out of the
political world for at least
a day or two no for at least several
months uh
two republican members of congress matt
gates
currently under investigation for a
litany of possible crimes
and marjorie taylor green anti-mask
anti-vaxx
congresswoman who regularly compares
things to the holocaust and then
apologizes for doing it
and then does it again they tried to
hold a press conference now
the press conference was meant to be
think about this
in defense of the january 6th trump
rioters
in defense of the rioters not the police
gates and green who normally claim to be
all about supporting the troops and
supporting the police
gates and green apparently believe that
the defendants
the the accused rioters are being
treated too harshly
by our legal system in terms of their
detentions and the like
this is not an issue they have any other
time except when you have
exclusively trump supporters having been
the alleged
perpetrators now all of a sudden they
care about the harsh treatment of these
defendants by the justice system
so they hold this press conference and
imagine
that being your primary concern related
to the january six riots instead of
actually investigating what happened and
who incited it
but that's their position so they try to
hold a press conference
when i say try i say that because it
goes hilariously off the rails
when protesters shut it down with
screaming and whistles
and our friend lauren windsor asking
matt gates
on repeat whether whether he's a
pedophile
let's get into the first clip uh and
what the funniest part of this one is
it gets shut down and louis gomer
a wacky republican congressman he sort
of tries to just keep going but nobody
cares once gates and greens start
leaving nobody even listens to louis
take a look at this it's everything
about it is perfect
the answers to the question we need we
need to break
the we need interrupting the press
conference we need to end it
thank you for those of you that really
care about it
this is just it's just amazing the
whistler
interrupts the press conference louis
gomer
tries to speak but it's just too late
nobody cares everybody's just leaving
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen what you just saw
here today is again the intolerant left
and that the voice you heard there
is i guess an anchor of some kind for
the youtube channel right side
broadcasting network so
the whistles are just absolutely
fascinating
the entire thing gets shut down here is
um here's another clip of the whistler
really preventing this from even from
even getting going i mean it's really
incredible
so that's actually the whistler in the
yellow shirt if people are watching
right in front of the right side
broadcasting anchor just whistling and
[Music]
whistling
all right now i'm against uh hearing
loss
and doing anything that's going to force
hearing loss on people of course
um i think it is important to remember
that you know part
there is an onus on if you want to hold
a press conference in public
then there's the possibility that
because it's in public people are going
to
show up i think that it starts to get
over the line if you blow the whistle
really loud right in someone's ear
i'm i'm right there on that uh but um
the same way that you are choosing to
speak
in a public place people can choose to
yell or blow a whistle in a public place
as well um and then it all i mean just
the level of derailment is crazy let's
look at one more of these clips
it's a weapon now now this there were no
weapons at the
at the january sixth riots but the
whistle is a weapon now
i mean it's actually quite stunning how
much havoc and chaos
one guy with a whistle can actually uh
wreak
at this one event okay so then we get
into the point where
marjorie taylor green and matt gates
they essentially just get
run out and they start literally running
away with security or staffers or
whoever
and then this is where there's another
layer to the memetic aspect of this
matt gates start being at starts to be
asked on repeat
whether he's a pedophile and it turns
out that that's actually lauren windsor
who we we
is a you know no a friend of the show
take a look at this somebody take them
away
off they go you saw what happened here
shut us down
oh my god no obviously
child sex abuse and pedophilia is not
funny the
image of lauren with a huge camp like
who even uses a camera that big anymore
it almost could be a prop and it would
add to the comedic element
chasing gates and saying are you a
pedophile is amazing now we actually
have
lauren's video from undercurrent uh with
a different view on this take a look
excuse me are you a pedophile are you a
pedophile
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh man so just absolute and total chaos
and again it all goes back to
um there the whole point of this press
conference
was that yesterday we had the first day
of testimony in the house select
committee
um investigating the january 6 riots
and the reaction from matt gates
and marjorie taylor greene is
whoa they're really not treating the
accused
rioters very well in the justice system
and of course you and i
have been talking about the fact that
too often
non-violent defendants are held without
bail
or held with a bail that's too high for
them to make so they're stuck in
pre-trial detention
they can't mount a defense they're
unable to make money they're unable to
parent their kids if they have kids and
it just perpetuates the situation
we've talked about that when it comes to
non-violent uh defendants
they now are all of a sudden concerned
about bail being too high
or bail being denied to people accused
of actual violence in some of these
cases
and now all of a sudden they care and
they want uh criminal justice reform i
mean it's just
all completely and totally pathetic and
the entire thing getting shut down who
knew that a whistle i mean listen
i remember being eight i remember
wreaking havoc with a whistle
but i was never able to wreak this
amount of of havoc and it's
absolutely fascinating to see one of our
sponsors is
monk pack i try to just limit
how much sugar intake i have and it's
tough sometimes because
sweet things taste good that's just the
reality and that's why i love
monk pack keto granola bars so much they
are sweet and delicious
they're soft and chewy they've got a
slight crunch
but each bar has only one gram of sugar
two to three grams of net carbs and just
140 calories so they are
perfect for anyone doing keto or low
carb
or just if you're trying to limit sugar
they come in great flavors like coconut
cocoa chip
peanut butter blueberry almond vanilla
these are not those hard crumbly granola
bars you're used to they're chewy
with a ton of flavor i always have a box
in my pantry
it's great for a quick breakfast or a
snack when i'm working
monk pack is giving my audience 20 off
your first order
go to monkpack.com and enter the code
pacman at checkout